keine samplings gib mir ein apfel gibt
mir ein apfel nur ein apfel für mich da
ist anna zipse skills und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wir
spielen heute eine runde ultra hardcore
games auf das team zehn.de und ich habe
richtig bock diesen kleinen noten modus
mal wieder zu spielen denn ich mag ihn
obwohl ein kleinod modus ist liegt mir
sehr am herzen nicht passte gefällt mir
wirklich sehr gut ich saß gerade eben
dachte jetzt nimmst du mal wieder
hardcore auf für alle die das nicht
kennen
es ist quasi wie sowie games auf einer
map kann man das sein
ich glaube nicht oder nee das kann man
nicht sagen dass tag kommt man kann also
vergesst es wieder es ist wie also ist
es ist ein zweifel das kann man auf
jeden fall sagen brauche ich noch mastix
ich sag nein es ist weibel man drop du
in diese welt rein da endet sofort die
schutzzeit und man kann hier eben dinge
abbauen das funktioniert unter ganz
bestimmten bedingungen wenn man baum
abbaut also man hier ein blog vom baum
abbaut passiert dass der ganze baum dort
also so eine art im was mord wenn man
schafe gilt dann trocken die eben verden
leder und gebratenes fleisch oder steak
auch genannt in rauen mengen
das sind so kleine veränderung hier
eisenerzer job direkt barre und so
weiter und so fort aber das werdet ihr
alles sehen wenn ihr gerade jetzt mal
ein bisschen mehr dabei zuschaut
ich werde hier noch ein paar schafe
kirche und dann suche ich mir wie immer
eine natürliche höhle
ich finde diesen modus eigentlich so
schön dass ich mir gut vorstellen könnte
dem ein bisschen öfter zu bringen
übrigens es gibt auch eine border seht
ihr rechts dasteht distanz mitte und
boarder radius distanz mitte ist eben
mein abstand zur mitte der karte und der
boarder radius ist der abstand der
boarder zur mitte wenn man die boarder
läuft wird man natürlich schauen und
natürlich die wichtigste sache man reck
nicht in ultra hardcore games nur mit
köpfen
deswegen tut jedes halbe herr pfarrer
schaden richtig richtig weh deswegen
glaube ich hier mal lieber nicht so dumm
rein
sondern lieber ein bisschen smart ich
liebe das wenn sie wollen wir in
höhenrain stehen besser dem feiere ich
richtig aber bitte in richtiger höhe
louis das sieht doch mal sehr gut aus
kohle dass man nicht abbauen weil ich
ein bisschen aber ich meine mama
verstellt habe er schon eisen und was
auf zack ist doch direkt eisenbahn
ich habe schon mal hat sie gebracht hat
man kanal ich weiß aber nicht ob das
jeder gesehen hat wahrscheinlich nicht
deswegen steht mal herunter wo das schon
prima muss man auch höllisch aufpassen
wisst ihr was war das war das da oben
das war das hören könnt ihr das gesehen
habe ich manchmal dass lang ein alter
what the [ __ ] is schritt hierher
da ist doch was der trainer um steht
noch keiner locker easy warte ich freue
mich hoch bis vor kurzem aus die maus
war kurz und treppen
ich verstehe es nicht okay auch übrigens
grübelt ob teile des übrigen spectator
bakker okay also es war kein gegner
vorher okay gut zu wissen
ich singe gespenster eine runde alter
väter sitte linke ok kurz sich daniel v
sie versucht mich zu schlagen
ganz ehrlich hause das sag ich deine
mama reicht auch hause du bist mir schon
sehr oft negativ aufgefallen hier im
kindergarten und wenn ihr jetzt anfängst
core gamer luke den core gamer luke zu
schlagen der look ist wirklich ein guter
mann
lasst sie in ruhe beziehungsweise lasst
ihr nicht nur weil es gibt was war für
dich
du bist einfach experte das wasser
fließt es im kindergarten raus und leute
ihr wisst ihr wie toter mann aus dem
kindergarten aus fliegt voraus im
kindergarten m gab kurz den steinbrocken
ich bin heute wieder wissen sprach
bestätigt heute fördert die sich wundern
ok ich sehe immer menschen wenn ich nach
oben schaue alter schwede
das ist richtig komisch spectator berg
bin ich mal vermuten so hier kann man
auf jeden fall runter okay wir müssen
jetzt wirklich höllisch aufpassen
mit den ganzen körper dass die uns da
keine rein drücken sonst haben wir
nämlich ein kleines problemchen
ich hätte mir völlig erstmal
rüstungsteile kräften ihr habt recht
alle die das gerade denken
kurz knapp hinten kommt ok es dann zur
entrüstung
ansonsten läuft tiroler nicht ganz gut
dass plate erstmal zack zack zack speed
kräfte hdl gut
jetzt kriegen wir zwar immer noch
ordentlich schaden wir getroffen werden
aber nicht mehr ganz so viel wie davor
jetzt auch eine sehr sehr sehr fall ist
gesagt man einfach umrüstung in den
höhlen läuft weil man kann nie wissen ob
nicht hinter einem cri passport oder ein
zombie ehre was weiß ich
und wenn das passiert moment kann er
sich ob leute ich werd verrückt die
ganzheitliche gespenster über mir da
schon wieder sind es spectator aber so
viele leute können ja gar nicht
schmeckten
kann ich mir nicht wirklich erklären
woher genau ich alle beide wagen nicht
hochgehen nicht hochgehen ich hoch geht
okay bin ein skelett skeletts gesetz
gesetz gilt
alter schwede das gerät ist das
schlimmste was dem einen fall abbekommen
halbes jahrzehnt nix machen
shit deswegen meine ich geld ist die
schlimmste weil wenn man jetzt keine
komplizierten konstruktionen baut hat
man ungefähr keine chance da
schadensfall auszugehen
eigentlich könnte man das machen was
meint ihr also leute die uhc spielen von
euch findet ihr mann sollte man jetzt
auf ein skelett trifft er irgendwie groß
was bauen dass man das geld eben nur von
unten schlagen kann kleinen dass ich da
um oder man sollte einfach den sauren
apfel beißen und halt ein halbes herz
verlieren
was meint ihr das wirklich interessieren
schraps motten rein und ich sah mir noch
bis dahin weiter
die runde ist gleich vorbei os
runtergedrückt der kleinen menge halte
ich aber erstmal richtig viel reisen
können wir erst mal hier sagt buß zwei
eimer für lava und wasser würde ich mir
noch kommen auf jeden fall auch mal ein
eisen schwert vielleicht noch mal fix
warum nicht ich habe genug waisen es
geht nicht verletzt schneider zu sehen
okay wie kommen wir jetzt hier weg nicht
so nicht so auf jeden fall viel glück
gehabt alte dass da okay geht hoch dass
hier dieser boden wieder hoch ging so
zwei blöcke alter später tatsächlich
denken wir dann herz falsch einkassiert
sie wieder unachtsam aber wir könnten da
unten eventuell die das finden wir
darunter gehen was eigentlich extrem
seltsam seltsam seltsam ist ich werde zu
mächtig wird richtig wütend wenn ich
mich selbst korrigieren muss in den
aufnahmen dann werde man so was halt
haben noten so versprachen
ich weiß ich dass länder mit einfach
ruhe endermann ich tu dir nichts zu tun
mir nicht okay okay das skelett lag
alter mann über zwei minuten
ich will gucken irgendwas ist das
skelett
du schaust mich einfach du siehst mich
einfach nicht okay werden sogar gold
login so kann ich nämlich mal schön
schlagen die kleinen kinder darum sage
ich euch die worte leute macht somit
macht mir nicht nach ich bin ein
dummkopf
ich verwende böse sprache meinen videos
soll ich nicht mag hat ein vorbild sein
so zac rein da ok und der frist bis in
das gerät wo ist das gerät herunter
gehen ich muss man da geht ja nicht viel
zeit denn das wäre ein skelett aber wie
formal das gold hier mitnehmen kann
nicht schaden
ihr seht auch das gold drop waren so
jetzt wie immer auf der höhe kommen 21
wir müssen ein bisschen runter geht's
hier runter hier geht's runter ja nicht
allzu tief oder dass ich nicht schlecht
aus rogowski redskins gerät mit ok aber
z
heute wird der treffer nicht mal schaden
gemacht habt ihr das gesehen eine minute
noch wir müssen ganz wir müssen gas
geben
der treffer hat mir da dem nicht mal
schaden gemacht ich wurde getroffen aber
hab keinen kein knapp ein halbes jahr
verloren
sehr gut sei wie goldammer wir acht das
reicht von gold apfel sollten wir in
unserem kurzen leben auch mein appell
finden aber mitnehmen immer gut wo ist
der zweite einmal hab ich den weg
geschmissen
oje oje ich bin ein verwirrter alter
mann
nein da ist heute einmalig blind ok ok
gutes zeug ich bin ich verwirrt ich bin
jung und nice und smaghi und
orientierungslos bekam ich hier nein 25
sekunden reicht ist für die us da unten
kam wir müssen glaube ich so hoch
vielleicht europa
ecke dafür direkt hoch keine geduld der
junge gibt zehn horst nothbaum skeletts
gesetz geht ich gebe einfach keine
ahnung judo sie durch ihr und noch so
death match aber wohl gemerkt wo wir
sind direkt an der boarder deathmatch
wohlgemerkt ohne diaz darf ich sollte
mir auch im boden treffen acht ich habe
auch noch eine sache gemacht die nicht
so klug war und zwar mir noch keine
pfeile besorgt oder kaum pfeile das
könnt ihr mir mal probleme bereiten ich
brauche jetzt erst mal junge junge das
ist richtig kritisch okay okay ich
brauche einfach mal ein paar bäume ab
hoffnung hoffnungsvoll glaub ich ja
hoffnungsvoll durchaus hoffnungsvoll
ich hoffe ich einfach dass ihr mann
irgendwie nen apfel dropped hier so ein
baum abbauen
ich habe ja acht gold ich könnte mir
einfach noch mal gold auf wir machen
aber ich darf auch nicht vergessen dass
dem ich vorne hinten errichten wollen
die pizza keine samplings gib mir gib
mir ein apfel nur ein apfel für mich da
sein
doch wieder hat könig max ii pc geht
wieder in die vollen hier hat mir noch
nicht gegeben steht wie konnte
mitarbeitern apfel sei es okay jetzt
nicht sterben nicht sterben nicht
sterben ich sterben alles gut alles gut
aufpassen einfach aufpassen er hat mir
auch wenn sich ein paar fälle gegeben
nämlich mal so profitabel ist nicht
wahrscheinlich hatte er aber egal
okay so bolt apfel rainer mit gut wir
legen jetzt wieder war sehr schön
sieben gold haben wir noch asche das
reicht von weiteren okay aber ist
erstmal egal wasser einmal sollte man
nur mitnimmt
da und immer noch vier einmal wieviel
gegner gibt doch es gibt noch einen
gegner
nein hier raus hier aus heroes heroes
hier raus die bohrer kommt man diese
hektik ohne gott so jetzt noch ein
bisschen wasser der andere hat ein herz
weniger als wir hat er nicht mehr darum
ist er die aktuelle rally als ob der typ
der schule hat junge ok hat ein treffer
passiert schon mal direkt das ist gut
ist auch runtergefallen dabei gehen wir
mal alle pfeile ich habe mich echt
extrem wenig feilen
es wird auf jeden fall kein leichter
gegner
da ist es besser diese hatten die
erschwerten die schwerter wir können gut
kommen und wir können gut kommen und ich
blocke einfach hoffentlich bringt was
junge schöne runde wunderbar first ball
direkt das wasser heute hat es gut und
jobs